[Music]
all right let's do it let's do it
are we doing it we're doing it ha ha get
down get down
we're get down get down
- Tori my ass we wound huge in
battlefield named seed look that is any
of this supposed to mean anything
Wow I wanna be a wee and I'll do this
well this appears to be my only option
normal normal view
cow cow with the bow man I remember not
to say anything racist I will be him
o bergen model equipped with end oh yes
something along those lines shall happen
yes
and while the level was loading I fell
asleep see you tomorrow
wow this is not remotely boring at all
whoa where are we going Oh pick the bow
I'll pick it down about what is the mega
kill everyone button oh oh don't black
power
what's the block button Perry I should
maybe look at the instructions before
it bugs Wow well maybe I don't need
instructions Kazuto Oh Oh bounce some
onions I'm gonna eat those onions onion
I think I'm gonna go with the old turban
rebellion since that's my only object
it's like the Gimli of dynasty warriors
send me a peasants driven to this by
boredom from cutscenes hi old man I did
not know this oh I did something awesome
oh snap I'm on a horse I'm on a horse
woman hey you can't jump on a horse
because horses can't jump things barely
that's how things work in this world
there are cotton to save the day hey
anybody know where the oats are coz my
horse is tired dust I'll have a mug of
ale for me and me horse for we have been
pitched in battle of fortnight to never
kings thirst for the frosty brew that
doubts might happen ah oh oh I'm gonna
kill van Chang he's gonna be angry in
the afterlife I got you chest of papers
oh now it's my turn gasps it's on I'm
gonna not even hit you once that love
dynasty Warriors on the eighth version
still using music from 1980
I believe me later
horsing turn hey come here buddy hey
don't run away from me far laughs hey
the pays the bills around here
you're supposed to blues but hey I'm in
the hood I'm in a hut cow cow you are
not helping the battle at all
unbeliev me later
holy snap I just did some kind of a
thing I'm like a god kick your ass
that's what you get for joining the guy
and you're a peasant I'm royalty of some
kind
hey pop give me a horse and I'll run
find my way to the actual battle here we
go ah the place we were 5 minutes ago I
can't understand a damn word you're
saying speak English speaking English oh
boy you did captain you were dead I will
just trample you until you were gone hey
the chit's are gonna have their way -
nah she'll be dance oh I want that yeah
what did it do oh I've got a taste of my
own medicine
oh no and another taste it's nasty
well he's blocking everything I'm doing
I think
this is just a bunch of noise but it's
fun noise because I've had alcohol hog
blood in my blood in the blood of my
blood in now it's not in my blood in my
urine
I slice you like a ham in the deli she
was angry that day my friends like an
old man trying to send back soup in the
deli brothers brother's car aha
Jubei we've managed to save these people
from sup some kind of thing Allah Allah
can you guys even see how much of a
badass I am like you're getting a boner
is it just me